this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print on the ramsey networks is my
co-host today as we talk about your
mental wellness your relationships your
jobs your careers and your money it's
your life right here on the ramsey show
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five austin is in
springfield missouri to start off this
particular hour hey austin what's up
hello dave nice to talk to you you too
how can we help
my question is i'm 22 years old and i'm
wanting to start investing
and i'm wanting to know
which platform i should use
wise man all right so you're out of
college you're working
i did not go to college i'm working i
actually own a construction and
exhibiting business of my own way to go
man that's incredible okay so what's
your income for the year household
income my
my income is around 45 000 a year
cool
and i i do own my house it's completely
paid off wow
what's that worth
my home appraised around 220 000
way to go man well you're doing great
already right off the bat you're killing
it you have any debt
no i know credit card debt or student
loans nothing and you have an emergency
fund you have savings three to six
months expenses yes
yes my emergency fund is around 25 000.
would you run for congress
22 years old you have your crap together
more than any of them at the island of
misfit toys
i i wish but um very um i got a lot of
my information from you dave obviously
and plus my family and my parents they
blessed
um me with a lot of knowledge and stuff
but no handouts but a lot of knowledge
and i'm very grateful for that yeah they
raised a great kid man well let's talk
about the investing side now have you
invested at all in anything so far or is
this all new
no sir i have not um started investing
at all um
in any type of cryptocurrency or
anything
all right well here's what i would do if
i were if i were you in your shoes i
would be investing 15 of my income into
retirement accounts so things like a
401k if you have access to that i know
you've got your own business but you
don't so it be a solo 401k or a sep ira
for you
but iras and those kinds of retirement
accounts is where i'd be putting that 15
and you can you can put a lot of money
in there if you're self-employed yeah
you can put six thousand dollars into
just a simple roth ira that's a very
easy transaction and that would that
would be pretty close to your 15 at this
stage of the game so what you do just
click on at ramseysolutions.com just
click on smart vester pro
sit down with one of the people that we
endorse for investing we call them smart
investor pros you're the smart investor
they're the pro that helps you do it
you're a smart investor and you are you
are you qualify dude well done but they
can set that up and you can have it come
out directly out of your checking
account monthly if you want to break it
down monthly be 500 bucks a month if you
want to do it one time in a lump sum you
can do that
i'd recommend just setting up a monthly
draft
because i like getting smart things on
autopilot
so i never have to think about them
again so i'm automatically smart i like
that i like that you can automate
smartness that's a i don't know
smartness not a word i'm not there yet
i'll get there smartness smart whatever
it is that's whatever whatever it is it
falls that wisdom we're going to just
put it on autopilot and where we
automatically are smart and i just i've
always try to do that trick myself into
doing smart things and you learn to live
on whatever's left and then you're
really winning exactly well done austin
sharon's in san antonio hi sharon
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys dave pleasure to speak with you
i appreciate your time thank you so much
i um i'm in a position where i'm able to
pay off my ex-husband's house for him
why and i was wondering if you thought
that would be a good idea well it sounds
weird
who pays off their ex-husband's house
he's a really really really good man and
he deserves a break he needs kind of a
hand
um
up and i just wanted to help him i'm i
um so is george just send him the money
i will take it a lot of good people out
there you could give to so that's some
strange generosity yeah that's different
is that weird i don't know no it's okay
it's just it's i mean if you want to do
it i'm not mad at you it's just would
you have to admit it's highly unusual
yeah like i don't think in 30 years i've
ever gotten this call
oh okay yeah i'm not trying to buy his
affection i don't want to get back
together with him he's just a good man
so how much do you how much does he owe
on his house
135
and you have like extra 135 000 laying
around
yeah i have four and a half million in
assets plus a trust fund that's two
million
okay
um oh can i by the way i'm working with
one of your um endorsed local providers
here in san antonio can i say his name
uh jeff whalen and the whaling wealth
team right fabulous that's awesome how
long have you been divorced
um we got divorced in 2016.
we were married for 18 years no children
um
where did you get all this money where'd
all this money come from
um my my parents and then and then they
passed away and my brother was sitting
on it and then he passed away
in 2020 and then he did not have a will
so i had a heck of a mess on my hands
so i had um
excuse me everything went to me
um and uh so that was that so you're
like what 50 you're 50 something years
old
i'm 53 years old yesterday and what do
you do for a living
i have a part-time job i do customer
service over the phone for
a company here in san antonio okay
all right
um
well there's nothing
legally wrong with this there's nothing
morally wrong with this there's nothing
um
uh mathematically wrong with this you
have the money you won't even notice
out of four right five million dollars
losing giving up 135 000
um
i think it's just suffice it to say it's
just strange enough that um from a
relational standpoint or an emotional
standpoint you know you might want to
talk this through with like your pastor
i'm not saying don't do it but you have
to admit that it's weird and you know
it's just it is and so
if you want to go do it that's fine
so
you know i don't know yeah i mean i
guess i'd i'd wonder his situation
financially is he good at money
management is this going to make him
feel like he just got a free ticket uh
if he hasn't been handling his money
well you don't want to be enabling in
that situation but
i mean it sounds like he's got a normal
mortgage like a normal person and she
just wants to rid him of it but i'm
still taking a nice long pause before i
catch the check
i just think of a whole lot of things
i'd put in line in front of it if it was
me doing it but you know you have a
sweetheart honey there's no question
about that and
it's your money and you're not doing
anything wrong and
[Music]
even if it's unusual it's okay to do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost-sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
well we learned we launched our first
stop on our wealth building live tour
recently the response has been
incredible if you haven't heard we're
taking our building wealth live event on
the road this year building wealth is a
hot topic everyone's got an opinion on
how to build wealth whether it's crypto
or single stocks or zero down real
estate and then inflation has everybody
freaking out we're going to walk you
through what's going on today and teach
you how to build wealth
really
the financial principles we teach are
the only principles that work in
prosperous times and in hard times it's
the quickest and surest way to become a
baby steps millionaire so we're taking
this event on the road we're going to
see you live and in person we can't wait
first stop orlando florida me rachel
cruz george campbell to my right dr john
deloney and ken coleman we're bringing
the building wealth live tour to you
orlando may 19th
stay tuned we're going to be announcing
other cities soon one of them sounds
kind of like las vegas
when you say it it sounds kind of like
that
and so uh not ready to announce that yet
but uh but soon soon and very soon
tickets started only 25 you can get a
four pack for only 60 bucks great deal
to do that bring another couple bring
you know four of you go out to dinner
for if you come over to building wealth
live and uh man 60 bucks that's a deal
and a limited amount of tickets left in
orlando it is not sold out but it's
getting close do not wait visit
ramseysolutions.com
slash events
to learn
even more our question of the day comes
from blinds.com
you find out for yourself why they are
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from helen in michigan she says
i'm looking to build a home i have
enough save for 20 down and have no debt
with current wait times should i wait to
build until prices start to come down or
should i go ahead and start the building
process before mortgage interest rates
go up more as i heard they are going up
soon
all right fair question there from helen
well i don't like uh making decisions
based on what might happen and so i feel
like if she's got the money to do this
right now go ahead and start the process
there's nothing wrong either way um
you know there is no question that
there's a shortage of labor right now in
the building world and that the building
material prices have still not
adjusted back to reasonable
uh after covid some of them have i mean
lumber went way up and then it's back
down
it's not all the way down though
um and so i think you're going to see
some smoothing out of
the cost of the house could be offset by
the increase in interest rates which we
have seen it
interest rates actually tick up
uh how much more are they going to take
up i don't know and is it going to
offset the cost savings so it's
completely up to you i can tell you this
building a home today at this moment if
you broke ground today in most cities is
going to be more stressful
because you're going to have shortage of
stuff shortage of labor
and uh and it's going to you know it's
just going to take a little longer to
build the house it's going to have a
stress factor to it that is very real
you got to watch it watch it like a hawk
you got to be keeping up and there's
going to be things that go wrong they
don't get right and so it's it's a side
project exactly so you know it just
depends on how happy you are on this you
know i mean
but there's not a there's not like oh
don't do it now no matter what or you
got to go right now you know neither one
you you're okay whichever one you feel
best about you're probably going to
you might see a little higher interest
rate and a little cheaper price
and a little smoother build
if you wait
if you're willing to go ahead and do it
now you got more known factors to george
george's point we're not gonna we're not
doing what we're gonna worry about might
happen we kind of know yeah where you
are right now and now with interest
rates dave you've seen them where
they're skyrocketing
right now if they go up we're not
talking eight ten percent yeah no
they're not you know they're at what
four percent somewhere around there
right now so we're not going to see
i mean if we did it'd be highly unusual
uh the number of times in 30 or 40 years
that i've seen interest rates move
more than one or two percent in a year
is highly unusual
and so you just you know you're gonna
see quarter eight that kind of stuff
movement
um and we've already seen that a little
bit but it's just it's this little tick
but it does it does change the payment i
mean it does change with you you know
what it costs you to buy the house
sarah's with us in boston hi sarah
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dan how are you better than i deserve
what's up
uh thanks for taking my call um i we had
a situation come up yesterday started
filing
our taxes and realized that we made too
much money for the roth ira
contributions we did last year
um which is a little bad problem i guess
but i'm trying to figure out
what to do
with that money whether we move it to a
traditional or pull it back we thought
we were being smart last year and over
contributed beyond the 15
that you recommend
and
so i'm wondering about pulling that back
and putting it towards our mortgage
no
it's not necessary
did you do it through smartvestor pro
we did not okay
well i mean did you do it on your own or
did you have an investment advisor
we have an investment advisor so call
them and tell them they need to call
them and tell them they need to undo it
and do a backdoor roth
back a backdrop yeah
and what that is they'll have to undo
this contribution
and then you will then you will open a
new
after tax
ira traditional after tax ira
and instantaneously roll it into a roth
and you can do that regardless of your
income
it still gets the money into a roth but
it just is gonna you're gonna have to do
the two step here to get it there
is that different than a traditional ira
then yes a traditional ira's pre-tax
and grows
tax deferred with taxes on it a roth
right does not grow
is not pre-tax it's after tax
and it grows
without taxes so what the what the
traditional after-tax ira is is just
like a roth you're putting the money in
after tax but then you can roll a
traditional to a roth regardless of your
income
okay and that's what you're doing so
you're just using a it's called it's
called a back door roth and your advisor
can help you do that without any trouble
at all yep no need to freak out we can
undo this mistake luckily and it's a
great option and people are worried that
it could go away but for now it's here
and so it's a great option to take
advantage of to legally get into that
roth regardless of income i do them
every year as long as i can for sharon
and i and uh if you make over two
hundred thousand you don't qualify for a
roth married filing jointly and so
that's where you are all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five lara is in ann arbor
michigan hi laura welcome to the ramsey
show
hi thank you so much for having me dave
sure what's up
so um my husband and i are debt free
and
we just finished uh saving up a
long-term emergency fund
and um we're getting ready to uh move to
a different state
so we won't be around ann arbor anymore
but what we're kind of wondering is um
you know normally we would be moving on
to step baby step number four right
um but our question is is
um we have been renting and we would
love to buy a house
and we're kind of wondering where that
all fits in together
well that would be in baby step 3b and
so once people have that emergency fund
in place there's a few ways you can go
some people go ahead and start investing
15 and save for the down payment some
people if you can save up the down
payment within about two years or so you
can just pause investing altogether to
get that down payment saved up really
fast and then some people do a mix maybe
you invest up to the match and then the
rest is going towards the down payment
until we get the house
so there's a lot of options you can do
there depends on your urgency of needing
to get into this house and when you can
financially do that with your income
does that change like if we want to
save up to pay cash for a house
i mean it's going to take longer how
quickly could you save up and pay cash
how many years
um
not really sure i just don't want you to
save up for eight years and not invest
because you're saving up to pay cash for
a house so we want to begin investing as
soon as possible two years is about my
emotional limit
yeah and that's kind of where
our question is because we both we're
both 30 now you're fine
some people take a little time off like
george is saying and build up their down
payment
and if you want to do that it fits right
in our baby steps we have had people do
it and we so we gave it a name we called
it baby step 3b baby step three is the
emergency fund's in place then before we
go on to four we're going to temporarily
sit here in the middle and save up a
good down payment and that's all you're
doing and you can do that this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage matthew and vanessa are
with us hey guys how are you very good
how are you welcome you come sliding in
sideways barely making it from the
airport oh my gosh no i mean it was a
traffic jam in kentucky there was a
traffic jam up in kentucky just out in
the middle of nowhere yeah and we were
at a dead stop for about okay so i don't
understand why you're coming through
kentucky if you're from houston well we
we went to see the ark and the creation
museum in kentucky and so we ended up
staying in lexington oh yesterday and so
we we got up early and came here but you
didn't know about the world famous
kentucky traffic jam no no apparently
not yet because there's not one but yeah
okay
well congratulations guys how much debt
have you paid off so we paid off 213 13
900 goodness how long did this take
58 months five eight five eight 58
months yes and your range of income
during that time so we started this
journey separately before we were
married and so my income was around
thirty six thousand hertz was around ten
thousand
um and we got all the way up to about
125 000 and we're back down to about
114. cool what do y'all do for a living
um i'm a gis analyst
and i'm an accountant
very good
so this is a
five-year deal here
how long have you been married uh we've
been married about three and a half
years okay
so what what was the debt what was the
214 thousand so 50 000 was our student
loans and then the rest is our mortgage
you paid up your house yes look at it
weird people
you're strange i love you how old are
you two i'm 30. i'm 28. and you're a
paid for house
that's so weird
it's unbelievable what's the house worth
uh it's worth about 250 right now
and it's yours
yes i love it
yeah baby wow what in the world inspired
you to do this at your young age this is
amazing uh i heard about you in college
but i didn't really start following you
until i got my first big boy job
um because i just didn't make enough
income uh but honestly whenever i first
started i just didn't want to be
homeless
uh so just paying my bills basically and
then i just kind of got inspired by
hearing all these people paid off their
mortgage and so uh before we were
married i set a goal for us to
for whenever we bought a house to pay it
off by time um i was 35 but we obviously
blew that goal out the window so
so yeah
so whose idea was it to not only tackle
the student loans but the mortgage too
uh it was mine uh i'm i'm a big dave
ramsey nut so
uh um so if you go in you're going all
in yes i'm all in or all out and so this
plant plan fit me perfectly especially
since i'm just like a gifted saver
and i just love being able to see that
bank account grow and so um having no
debt is obviously the key to becoming
wealthy so yeah way to go so vanessa he
told you this is what he's do you know
this is how it's our role what'd you say
i was a little hesitant at first yeah
like are you sure
and then um as we went on and we paid my
student loans off i was like maybe we
can do this i can see it now yeah so i'm
curious you guys did all this in your
20s most people in their 20s say well
dave ramsey's playing me i'm not going
to have a life i'm going to miss out on
my entire life do you feel like that
have you done this uh no honestly i mean
we still did like a trip to san antonio
and then last year we went to uh but
right before we played the house off we
went to daytona international speedway
because i'm a big nascar fan
and uh but we still went out to eat i
mean we still hung out with friends but
we didn't just sit there and scrap lent
the whole week and sit there and live on
beans and rice
i mean our budget bill our
grocery bill wasn't tremendously large
but we still did some some things and
still ate out and um like i said we
didn't just uh stay home all the time
so dave ramsey didn't scar your youth
that's good okay no he helps my youth
george thank you i've been redeemed i
want to sell your goodness just want to
make sure we make sure we get that out
there for you people that uh yeah good
for you guys way to go you're incredible
how does it feel to be completely
free
it it's it's amazing unreal amazing i
mean the sky is the limit right now on
what we can do
william we're already being able to
bless people and it's such a blessing to
us
we're about to lead our eighth fpu class
next week um and we've had a total of
almost 230 000 paid off in all our
classes
um at our church and uh we're just we're
thrilled that we're built that we're
gonna be able to help people and that
we're gonna be able to be outrageously
generous
wow way to go what a testimonial now as
you lead more classes you go we gotta
pay for a house wow yeah that means
because you know there'll be some guy in
there that thinks he's got it all
together and then they're looking at
this guy he's 30 years old with a paid
for house so that kind of like is shut
up right yeah great testimony there very
cool way to go you guys whoo
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is uh beanie babies
and pokemon cards
no not really not really not really just
uh he's been saving that one out there
while he was sitting in traffic he
dreamed that joe actually yeah he
actually mentioned it whenever we were
in traffic
i just had to stick that one in there
dave i don't know
i could tell but uh no i think just
perseverance and just uh having a vision
beyond just friday
um that i mean
that it's just it's totally worth it and
that people definitely need to get on
this plan even if it means sacrificing
two or three years of your life to do it
like i said it's just totally worth it i
i don't even know how to explain it what
how to explain it whenever we pay the
mortgage off um
it was i just wanted to jump all the way
to mars um
like i feel like i could defy gravity at
that point
but
but knowing that our kids aren't going
to have any debt in the future
is is tremendous because that was one of
the goals of ours was to have no debt
whenever we had kids mom dad not
pregnant i'm i'm sorry
um but uh uh
but um just being able to change our
family tree and be able to be generous
um to whoever needs it at
that time
um and that we're gonna be able to
spread god's work um because we're we're
completely debt free and that we're
financially stable
well way to go you guys
very cool
very cool
good work good work well we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that is definitely the next chapter in
your story you're heading that direction
very very quickly
and uh how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too
number one best seller
and uh on top of that of course we'll
give you a total money makeover book for
you to give away and continue to stir up
a ruckus with that thank you for leading
the classes you guys are incredible i'm
so proud of you thank you thank you very
much very very very well done who were
your biggest cheerleaders
uh
i would say my parents my parents also
yeah uh i think her uh her father her
stepfather was completely baffled and
amazed that we paid off our mortgage in
basically three and a half years because
they still have a mortgage and so uh so
i was just uh so like i said he was just
baffled and my dad paid their house off
when they were 39
um and stuff so i'm just having that
inspiration and i kind of had a bet with
my dad that i was gonna pay that we were
gonna pay our house off before
before uh 39 years old and obviously we
blew that out of the water yeah for sure
so they're super proud of us um
and and all that so you did it before
vanessa was 29 so there you go yeah yeah
well well she was actually 27 when we
paid the house oh wow
and it kind of i was kind of the one
thing i was bummed about was i turned 30
last year in april so i missed um paying
the house house off in my 20s by like
five months
shucks oh wow
i'm bummed about that
you're killing me here
well done guys very well done all right
it's matthew and vanessa houston texas
214
000 paid off in 58 months that's their
house and everything
at 30 years old and under man making 30
making 46 up to 125. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
there is hope dave there's hope no there
is i tell you what you take a house
payment
two thousand
twenty five hundred
put that in the growth stock mutual fund
from 30 to 60.
you're going to have a
lot of millions
a lot of millions just from the house
payment alone yeah this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five matt is in minneapolis
hi matt welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me on sure
what's up
well my wife and i finished baby step 2
last june
and we are we
currently
have sold our house now this past
november uh my wife had a calling and uh
works at our church and
through that uh we just decided the best
plan for our budget was to uh sell our
house we're currently renting looking
for a little bit of a downsize uh we did
have a net gain of 190 000 off of the
sale of our house and
my wife and i also have some traditional
401ks from previous jobs that we had in
the amount of just under 200 000.
wondering if it makes sense to take some
of that
uh profit that we have from the sale of
our house and roll those into a roth
no
not until you get a house purchased and
have it paid for
okay okay because what you're doing is
creating a tax bill
that you're paying with money that you
would use to put a larger down payment
on the house and thereby getting you out
of debt faster on the house and so the
net result after you purchase the house
would be as if you borrowed on your home
to pay the taxes from doing the rollover
because it's going to create more debt
on the house if you use some of this
money for taxes right
yep yeah so that makes sense yeah i
don't want to do that i do want people
to roll to uh ir or to roth's as um
as you get into baby step seven and can
find extra cash to do it
so i've converted everything into roth
years ago
um and and paid those taxes and i
convert the
even the match any of you that get a
match it's not allow if you have a roth
401k like we do
uh i do a roth 401k for myself at my
company uh the match by law cannot be in
roth and so it's traditional but once a
year i go ahead and roll it
at the end of the year all of the match
over into the roth portion and pay the
taxes on it i create a tax bill to keep
moving it that way but i've got the
extra cash after being 100 debt free in
baby step 7 which is where i'd want you
to do this yeah so this 190 000 would
then become sounds like your down
payment on your next house i put as much
down as possible to get paid off as
early as possible yes and then continue
to invest 15 of your income aside from
that into retirement yeah and then get
the house paid off and once it's paid
off then we'll do this it's a wise
decision just wrong timing yep very very
good and it's a good question yeah i
like the question donna's in hartford
connecticut hey donna what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
so my question is really surrounding
whether or not to look into long-term
care insurance how old are you nine my
husband's 57 oh okay
um
basically our health care coverage when
we retire at 65 or 67 will be great
it's a government sponsored after
medicare
and our income not including
investments at 65 or 67 going forward is
going to be about 100 a year
and how much will you have in your nest
egg
how much will you have in your nistic
um currently in investments we have a
million
by then i would say a million and a half
um so
and then like i said our income not
including that will be about 100 which
was kind of our goal to be at at that
time yeah
well the statistical evidence is is that
the the less than one half of one
percent people use long-term care
insurance for nursing home or in-home
care prior to age 60
and you're approaching 60 uh and so do
you want to insure against nursing home
stay the average stay is 2.3 years
uh the average cost right now is about
90 000 a year so it's about a 250 000
exposure on average
um and you know can you insure through
that for a while yeah i probably would
in your case
because i mean if you use 300 000 out of
a million that's a pretty good chunk
now if you get to 2 million and you say
all right i'm going to take a 300 000
risk out of my 2 million
so your husband goes into a nursing home
stays there 3 years you pay take 300 000
out of your 3 million
um pay his care he dies you're left with
2.7
you're self-insured through the nursing
home at that point you see what i'm
doing
no i don't really want to do that with
just a million
yeah i think we'll have a million and a
half yeah but still i mean do you want
to be if you want to if you're okay with
a million two on average
yeah
it might be longer it might be less but
75 percent of the ladies outlive their
husbands
true
and so and i don't even know how much it
costs i've heard it's ridiculous and
they cancel on you
uh the the long-term care insurance
yeah yeah they don't no i don't i've
never i mean there's a few of them are
have been some of the companies were
weak and they collapsed but i think that
most of that's behind us don't buy any
cash value insurance versions of it
but uh you can shop it we've i mean we
recommend long-term care insurance
uh and so and i probably would look at
it in your case until you get up above a
couple million dollars and then drop it
so you might keep it like three or four
years or something and then drop it uh
and self-insure after that point but
just check long-term care elp
endorse local provider at
ramseysolutions.com it's you'll find the
people we recommend they're a broker
they'll shop among different companies
explain it to you help you get the right
coverage you don't need to buy it until
you're 60 but you're coming up on it
pretty quick here so you can start
learning about it shopping it being
ready get ready to budget for it yeah
yeah and it's doable i mean you got the
money either way you're not it's not
gonna take you out
the ones that concern me the most out
there george are the ones that have
three hundred thousand dollars
you got no money toppa goes in the
nursing home
scrambles that nest egg you have
scrambled eggs right i mean you got
nothing left crack and scramble the nest
egg
and that 300 is wiped out you're broke
and he dies
and she's left broke
and nursing home you know the nursing
home take his care used up what they had
and so in a situation like that it's
just absolutely vital that you get
long-term care insurance
but uh but i'm 61. i don't have it
but i've got you're selling i'm
self-insured you're okay to foot the
bill i think we can handle it i think we
can handle it
so um and sharon will outlive you you're
thinking
i think that's pretty well assured okay
because he's in great health yeah well
i'm on top of everything i mean all of
our estate plan is predicated on me
pre-deceasing her so i'm kind of
sleeping with one eye open i think she
has a plan i'm kind of worried about
those must be fun family meetings
the dave's going to die meeting
matt's in rochester new york hi matt
welcome to the show
hey how are you guys doing today great
man what's up
so i'm 23 years old and i've been
investing in both of 403 b and then my
roth ira
and since listening to you guys i've
been learning about the rollover roth
iras and i was just wondering if that's
a route i should do while i'm when i'm
this young
um so it's kind of a question about that
a rollover
roth there's no such thing unless you're
rolling an old ira into a roth
so you can only roll a traditional ira
into a roth ira
correct or you could roll a one roth
into another roth i mean you can move
the money around but there's not a right
there's no such thing can you roll what
can i roll my 403 b into a roth ira yes
so
uh
would you recommend doing that since no
because it's going to it's going to
create taxes
okay i mean if you if you move 10 000
over there you're creating a 3 000 tax
bill
would that save me and more taxes come
long term since in the roth it could
grow tax-free and come out tax-free yes
which is why we recommend a roth instead
of traditional but
you paying taxes while you've got
probably some other goals i'm guessing
you're going to pay off some debt have
an emergency fund in place pay off your
house you need to do those things first
right george yeah are you in are you in
debt right now i'm guessing he's not
probably okay
but yeah that would be the order to do
it like we were talking with the other
caller we got to do this once we have a
paid for house then we can afford the
tax bill and we have no other big
financial goals in front of us other
than to build wealth right all of your
future contributions if your 403 b
offers a roth 403 b i like that make
your future contributions all roth if
you can
everything you can do roth now is good
but uh but
i'm not gonna create tax bills while i
still got debt on your house or anything
else and i'm guessing based on your age
that you probably still have a few of
those things
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
if you haven't joined us in a while
we're the people that tell you to get on
a budget
so that you can live on less than you
make
so that you can get out of debt
so that you can build an emergency fund
when you got your emergency fund you can
begin to build wealth and when you build
wealth you can change your family tree
and when you change your family tree you
position yourself and your family to be
outrageously
generous
that's in game
for everything we teach you we want to
set you up to be outrageously generous
the rest of this stuff is just a path
that way it's what we do joining me uh
this hour joining me and george this
hour is a good friend of ours scott
harrison he's the founder and ceo of
charity water which is a non-profit that
has mobilized over 1 million donors
around the world to fund over 28 000
water projects in 26 countries that
serve more than 8.2 million people this
is a charity of scale water is a big
deal and uh of course this is the week
when we had international water day
right scott that was yesterday yesterday
well almost like we planned this or
something who knew i didn't but yeah i'm
glad we did it perfect stuff
so uh the whole clean drinking water
thing
is
in my mind i mean there's so much that
uh nothing can happen until you start
with that
right in a developing country i mean in
any situation but but if you don't have
water
you spend all your time and energy
getting water and you can't move on to
any other parts of your life it really
starts there it's such a basic primal
thing that's right and as we sit here
771 million people don't have it wow one
in 10 people alive
so that's two americas full of people
living around the world that don't have
that basic need met
and so they spend an inordinate amount
of their day
walking for it miles and miles and miles
to get one pot to come back and then do
it again tomorrow yeah and it's the
women and the girls that are you know
bearing this burden uh i remember when i
started i came across the stat that 40
billion hours are wasted just by women
in africa walking for water so you have
an unrealized economy
of time that could be turned into
productive work
entrepreneurship you know selling things
at the market leading families and
communities
wasted seven days a week walking for
unsafe water not even useful water
[Music]
the
chair the the organization is charity
water if you want to learn more about it
and how you can give charitywater.org
dave
jump over there and you can find our
portion of the site we got to know scott
uh several years ago and i think the
first thing that attracted me to you the
charity is amazing and the water
the the act the actual end product of
what you're trying to accomplish is
uh world-class and such an up again a
primal need and it frees up so many
things
but the thing that i ended up connecting
with you most on was that you went out
the whole charity thing
a different way rather than just begging
for money kind of thing well i started i
was 30 years old i had this experience
as a photojournalist on a medical
mission where i'd seen people drinking
dirty water made that connection to
health
and came back and said i want to try to
get everybody on earth clean water
i talked to people who were my age and
they were cynical and skeptical about
charity everybody seemed to have
something they could pull out of their
back pocket of a charity gone wrong
whether it was mismanagement of funds or
some sort of scandal so
i thought what if we could tell people
that a hundred percent of everything
they would ever give would go directly
to fund these water projects which we'd
prove on google earth and google maps
and then in a separately audited bank
account i would raise all the overhead
from a small group of business owners
and entrepreneurs and donors so it would
kind of church and state
you know those nasty epson copy toner
costs and the staff salaries in the
office would be paid for by
today about 100 families where millions
could give and know that all their money
goes a hundred percent of your donations
even pay back credit card fees which
sounded like a great idea uh when you're
not at scale and now it's getting close
to a million dollars but if you went
online and gave a hundred dollars right
now in your amex we get 97. i wish we
got 100 but we get 97. we pay back that
three percent transaction fee and we
send and track the hundred dollars
wow
so that the whole hundred dollars
actually goes yeah you're not even
deducting that yeah and and you know 70
of americans polled uh by nyu recently
believe charities waste their money
so this is just one way to saying you
know all of it will get there
and the 100 families they love paying
for overhead they're building the
organization they are hiring and and
retaining talented staff so it actually
isn't that difficult it's just a
completely different value proposition
and we treat them like investors
they're stakeholders for sure no
question about it well it does make it a
lot a lot more
uh a lot easier emotionally
when you know 100 cents on the dollar is
actually going to the clean water yeah
and on top of that transparency scott
something you've done so well is
innovate in this space and the way
you've used technology
to connect people to what's happening
talk to us a little bit about that yeah
we were just we were the first
organization to publicly publish every
satellite image of every completed
project in the world
um we've now got you know close to a
hundred thousand
completed water projects across 29
countries uh more recently uh we have
been creating smart wells
so you know kind of in this internet of
things right nest or
you know these these remote devices so
we're creating wells in ethiopia and
malawi and india
that
uh basically broadcast their
functionality transparently to the cloud
so we know when a well breaks and then
we can dispatch mechanics to go and
bring that project back online so we're
now monitoring over a billion liters of
flow it's the largest data set in the
history of the world
when it comes to rural water supply
and you know then think of kind of geek
squad or or apple care turns up in the
village with wrenches
and the tools to
to make that maintenance call so really
just you know the innovation is for the
sake it's all for the sake of keeping
clean and safe drinking water flowing in
a sustainable way over time
wow that's powerful there's a lot going
on there very good stuff scott harrison
the ceo of charity water one of the best
non-profits in the world they've
mobilized over one million donors again
28 000 water projects uh the website
charity water
dot org slash dave uh this place around
here we're all about teaching you to be
generous and we want you to get out of
that get on a plan so that you have
money to be generous with and this is
the type of thing we want you to study
where you're learning where the your
generosity is not being all absorbed
this is why we know that taxation is not
generosity because a hundred percent of
it is absorbed in stupidity
and this is the exact opposite 100 of
this actually goes to the clean water
instead of being wasted in washington so
and there are charities that don't do a
good job uh and use up too much of the
money and administrative costs and so
forth and that's where that stereotype
comes from but this is one that's a
great guy a guy we've known for years
and we just wanted he was in the
building i wanted to stop by and give
you guys an opportunity to learn a
little bit about generosity learn a
little bit about charity a different way
of doing it and learn a little bit about
charitywater.org
dave scott thanks for dropping by
brother thanks for having me good to
have you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host over the last 30 years we've
walked with millions of people
to help them overcome their financial
stress
we found money stress is just one of the
ways we experience stress people
struggle with anxiety loneliness stress
all kinds of
mental wellness
issues here's the good news dr john
deloney ramsey personality has a new
book available for pre-order right now
called own your past to change your
future and it is selling like crazy
everyone wants and needs to know about
dr john dolone's book
it is a not so complicated approach to
relationships
mental wellness mental health
you're in for a treat when you read own
your past change your future you'll
laugh you may cry you definitely will be
challenged and if you take the steps dr
daloni outlines you will be transformed
own your past change your future we'll
show you how to deal with trauma
get connected in your community heal
relationships your mental health is
really important
so when you pre-order today we're going
to give you free bonus items would
include a month of free one-on-one
therapy
through our partners at betterhelp who
does that
that's all for getting a 20 book on
pre-order well you need to get it right
now because the book's going to come out
soon and the pre-order deal is going to
be gone so go to ramseysolutions.com
take advantage of this and we'll be
ready to roll patrick's with us in
springfield missouri hey patrick welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave
i am retired and i have 10 of my uh
retirement in
gold and silver bullion and coin
and my question is with the
disruptions in the economy due to
inflation the fed move the ukraine war
and possible
conflict with china in the future should
i
be invested in gold and silver
and if not is there an alternative
um
well i'm 61
and uh
i have a net worth of several hundred
million dollars
and i have zero invested in gold and
silver
it tells me a
lot uh and so you know it's consistent
in other words my advice is consistent
with what i do
in the last 10 years uh gold has
averaged 3.6
while the stock market has averaged
almost 12.
and so i um
and and the problem is that gold and
silver are not necessarily
what people will run to
unless they're just afraid or greedy one
of the two
uh and in other words a failed economy
that would rely on gold and silver will
before it uh relies on that will turn
into a barter economy
so you know uh
the only way that i mean gold and silver
does not have intrinsic value it has
absolutely no value except what someone
else will pay you for it
uh gold our green president's faces
on paper don't have any value except
what someone else will trade you for it
and so that's how exchange or currency
works it's when we as a society or as a
group of people agree that something has
value we agree that little shiny clear
rocks have more value than the rocks in
our driveway and we call them diamonds
but there it actually has no different
they're both a little rock
you know we just decided as a sir as a
society or a culture that there but
there's nothing that
automatically means that diamonds have
value
they don't
it's only because someone else wants
them that they have value and green
paper doesn't have value it's only it
doesn't it's only that someone else
wants it
that makes it have value so all of that
to say anytime you're investing in a
commodity
because you're worried about world
affairs
or stupidity on a global scale or
whatever it is uh you're really not
accomplishing
what you hope to accomplish there
if you you know and so you you kind of
got to go extreme before these things
happen and if you believe that america
as we know it is getting ready to
implode which is not what you said
but for those of you out there that
believe that
then gold is really not where you would
put your money you should put your money
in water bottles bottles of water
bullets
blue jeans and gasoline practical things
because these utilitarian things are the
first things that happen in a completely
devastated
society you know you start fresh
and so
and you know you could trade a gallon of
gas where there is no gas for almost
anything it becomes
like gold so what happens you end up
trying to trade your gold bar for a
gallon of gas it won't work nobody wants
it gold bart you just gotta carry your
stupidity with a gold bar there was a
youtube video of this kid he tried to
live on gold bars for 24 hours as an
experiment he couldn't do it
nobody would take it no one would take
it and then he went and rece he tried to
resell it couldn't get what he paid for
it oh wow that was a fun video fun
experiment yeah but all of that to say
um
you know i
i'll throw in one other thing patrick
i'm being a little bit facetious but i'm
really not you probably need to turn off
the news
i think you've been spending too much
time watching the news
uh because everything you just outlined
for me is a talking point on a 24-hour
news cycle
and it's affecting your
brain more than it's affecting reality
um
i mean
reality is gas has gone up
and that's really biden's fault
reality is because he's you know went
all green and shut off the faucet
anytime you create a shortage on
something you create a price increase so
if you want to be if you want to blame
somebody for five or six dollar gas you
can look at your president he did that
if you want to blame someone for an
increase in
car prices
he did not do that
it's not his fault he had nothing to do
with it if you want to other parts of
inflation you want to say you want to
blame someone for house prices going up
it's not joe biden's fault he didn't do
it he can't blame him for that
uh because he there's no policy enacted
by the white house or at his behest
through congress that caused
those things those things are the result
of the a pandemic
that created a shortage that drove
prices up
and so we have steel
prices are way up i'm building a
building up here commercial building
we're putting steel in it prices are
through the roof
we have a you know we have a shortage of
anything yeah yeah
but a shortage of anything drives the
prices up
an oversupply of anything drives the
price down
it's seventh grade economics class it's
called a supply demand curve and that is
not joe biden's fault
and so when the news is on and they're
going well the biden administration and
the the average consumer polls are
saying that everyone's mad at the
president about inflation well they're
just uninformed you shouldn't be mad at
the president about inflation you'd be
mad at the pandemic
but there's no greedy
you know boogie man out there trying to
create inflation it's going to smooth
out over time the only element of
inflation that is his fault and i'm 100
sure of this is is the energy issue
and he shut off all domestic production
and so created
a dead gum shortage
of oil and therefore of gas and now
you're having to pay
through the nose to get oil and gas and
we were buying 50 000 freaking barrels
from russia and guess what that's kind
of hard to do right now
so um
again
uh all in the name of being green
and so george could plug his car in
that's right thank you dave yeah we want
george to be able to plug his car in
it's important
that your toy car can be plugged in
their shots have been fired guys just so
you all know well listen dave aside from
that here's what's interesting you can
build incredible wealth and never turn
on the news
isn't that wild yeah higher probability
i i think we should do a study on that
statistically you will become a
millionaire faster if you never turn on
the news well i do know this i do know
that um my stress level goes down yes my
tendency to rage at something that has
nothing to do with anything
goes down well they're getting better at
writing these headlines it makes you
click it makes you angry
that's how this works yeah and it's all
of us are that way so just jumping in on
there on you patrick but um
you know i my money is in good growth
stock mutual funds and in real estate
that i pay cash for
that's all i own
i don't know anything else so sell sell
all that off and put it in mutual funds
you'll be better off in the long run man
i'm unusually heavy
in real estate but it's because i'm a
real estate guy i got my real estate
license in 1978 i've been doing real
estate a long time so i'm really
comfortable with dirt really comfortable
bricks and mortar really comfortable
being a landlord
doesn't bother me a bit other people
shouldn't do that because you're not
comfortable with it but
you know real estate
i'm there mutual funds i'm there
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage jason
is with us hey jason how are you i'm
well how are you better than i deserve
man fantastic so where do you live
albuquerque new mexico cool how much
debt have you paid off fifty one
thousand dollars
how long did that take in 16 months and
for 10 days good for you and your range
of income during that time uh started at
eighty two thousand a year and ended at
eighty three five good what do you do
for a living i work at a at the national
research and development laboratory
there okay cool very good
uh what kind of debt was the 51 000 a
little bit of everything except cars
actually uh it was uh i had a computer
two small student loans couple of credit
cards uh my second mortgage and
a large 401k loan cool okay
so what uh prompted this journey on this
ramsey stuff 16 months ago it was uh
yeah there was a friend of mine that i
work with my friend justin we were
looking at 401k numbers and how much can
we
if we put in this much it'll grow to
this much and you know we just started
talking about numbers and i was like you
know i need to pay off some debt and i
was like i got a lot of bills so
it just started that he mentioned your
name and asked if i had had senior
program i was like you know i've heard
of him but i haven't really looked into
it and so he sent me a couple of videos
and then i started binge watching videos
and just it just went from there wow
wow
good for you man cool
so uh you sit down and just say that's
it i'm doing it yeah i i
probably researched it and watched
videos for
a couple of weeks solid and i was like
okay okay and then
and then once i the hardest one was the
first one and i just
decided after that it was done
after that i was on a roll okay but you
learned enough just from the youtube to
figure out what to do youtube and your
website and
you know just i i got on the facebook
dave ramsey baby steps facebook and good
and just started asking all kinds of
questions and
researching all i could and and just
went from there yeah well they'll give
you an answer on that they're happy to
answer yes amazing they're a chatty
bunch so tell me about the second
mortgage
second mortgage uh it was a cash out and
the money went toward
you know who knows what
who knows
but uh i yeah
that was that was a big one but the uh i
think one of the hardest ones to pay off
was a 401k loan because i had to put it
all down all at once yeah that was the
last one
so man good for you who was your biggest
cheerleader
uh well this little guy no son but uh i
you know family friends um a friend that
i met on the baby steps facebook group
my friend jen she's she's been huge the
whole time we've been talking ever since
my friend justin at work you know some
of the guys at work think i'm crazy some
of them yeah they're like man that's
great wow yeah that's good it's going
what's your son's name and age grayson
and he's 11.
11. and he was encouraging you the whole
time you got this dad yep very cool
that's huge that's very cool all right
now when people find out paid off fifty
one
thousand dollars in 16 months
and they say
how did you do that
what are you what are you telling the
key to getting out of debt is
just commit
i mean there's no halfway it's
start it
and go through it finish it that's i
mean you got to get on a plan that's
really the plan was
that was huge for me and
a budget i'd never budgeted before in my
life and uh when i did my first budget
i found out that i'd been wasting a lot
of money every month
all of us had that experience brother
so uh
this feels like you sprinted
through it it does like you just weren't
hard at it yep uh
you think you'll stumble back into debt
now no
why not i
i'm sick of it i actually have money now
once you know what that feels like you
know i like this
look at this let's not go backwards
i like not being broke yes wow it's
different i mean you know it's i'm
through step three i'm into four five
and six now it's
it's great i feel the levity what was
the hardest part of the whole journey
the biggest sacrifice
um
i mean the hardest part was the first
payment and then the last one that was
the big one but
because i had all that money in my
savings i was like
i have money
but
now i didn't really but you know but it
was the first time you had that level of
discipline to even save that up and not
spend it true
so you felt the pain of that but then
you felt the freedom soon after i mean
almost instantly yeah wow so so how's it
feel now
it's great
you know we're on vacation and we're
swimming and
life is good life's good yeah i like it
i like it well done feels great good job
jason we're very proud of you man thank
you very studly very well done you too
grayson good work brother
good work i like it we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
heading that direction and a copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away and stir up a holy ruckus somewhere
we'll do so very very well done good
stuff
all right it's jason and grayson from
albuquerque new mexico
51 000
paid off in 16 months
making 82-83 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream ready
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
i love it
that is excellent
excellent job man that's fabulous
changes everything when you do that
it just changes
everything austin is with us in grand
rapids michigan hey austin what's up
how's it going dave how you doing better
than i deserve how can i help
well i had a question so i'm sorry is it
too echoing to remember
uh you're kind of going in and out can
you speak directly into your phone
yeah i certainly can do that give me
just a moment
uh try one more time austin
can you hear me
sorta you sound like you're in a barrel
now what'd you do
why don't you turn that one off why
don't you turn the speaker thing off and
just talking to the phone
actually just on the phone okay how can
we help
sorry
so the question was
refinanced my house
i was fortunate enough to buy it at a
time and gain enough equity through
remodeling to refinance it
um the reason i did so uh was because
when i originally purchased it i had to
put five percent down and had the uh the
old
pmi
so i was paying an extra 100 to 200
bucks a month on that
okay
so if we
use the money and the refinance i had
about eighty thousand dollars in equity
in house and i um the refinance will be
a cash out of fifteen thousand why
why are you going further into debt
right
so the idea was to
i guess consolidate loans that were
higher in interest and then to finish
off
some remodeling that i had to do
on the house you're gonna do all of that
with fifteen thousand dollars
um yeah actually i would oh so what's
your income
um currently well i get paid hourly so
base would be sixty six five a year with
overtime i'm usually around 70.
okay all right
no i would not do that i would cash flow
the repairs and i would cash flow
getting out of debt and i wouldn't go
further into debt
oh you know you're not really doing
anything here you're just moving debt
around you're moving it from one place
to another
it didn't get rid of it it's still there
uh and instead i want you to get rid of
it and so you need to roll up your
sleeves and punch this debt in the mouth
and get rid of it and you fix the house
whatever repairs you have left to do out
of pocket
uh sounds to me like you're a single guy
making 70 grand i want you to tighten up
your budget drop your dadgum lifestyle
down and clean this mess up don't try to
borrow your way out of debt
you can't borrow your way terrible
shortcut and it sounds like he already
did the cash out refund based on how he
was talking
that's even worse because now i don't
know how to undo it
i mean it sounds like he's going to do
it regardless yeah well there would be
no point in calling us then
he i think he wanted to know how to use
the cash i guess but he sounds like he's
gonna do these renovations and be done
with it but man it's you're going
backwards and it's a terrible shortcut
we want you to pay off your house not go
further into debt you can't get out of a
hole digging out the bottom people
that's not how you get out
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jessica is in dallas hi jessica how are
you
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um i have something that
i we just cannot figure our way out of
it and it's probably easier for you to
explain it to us
we have bought a house about three years
ago
decided on um installing solar panels
adding to the debt and
we do not make
but maybe
30 100 a month after child support
we
do not know which way is up we do not
know how to make ends meet
i've tried to start a stay-at-home
business while i stay at home with my
son and we are just
upside down on a lot of things um
what do you owe on the solar panels
they were just installed last year so
that's about thirty thousand dollars
what is it what do you owe in your house
we still about 197.
okay what's your house worth
uh
per open door it's worth about 300. okay
what other data have you got
we have about 15 grand in credit card
debt because we tried to make uh
make remodeling things happen when we
bought the house that didn't work
um
so yeah yeah so so of course i just
don't want to respond
on your cars
my stepdaughter we don't owe anything on
cars we're renting to own from a friend
of ours but we may likely just have to
give them back the car
[Music]
so you have two cars
we actually have three cars one was
gifted to us so there's no reason to
have the third uh
that's why we might just give it back
okay so you have one that's paid for one
that's and or you have two that's paid
for and one that's rent to home
correct yeah give it back today
yeah you're right you're right no i'm
not kidding it was not a joke no you're
right now yeah we we just discussed that
this morning before i can give you a
call okay um aside from that uh like i
said i i'm getting everything three
thousand dollar take-home pay three
thousand dollars how many kids have you
got
uh we have one child at home and then my
stepdaughter
and then your stepdaughter what
your stepdaughter is not at home
you mean your partial custody with her
partially yes okay all right i see and
how old's your baby that's at home
he's three
okay
all right and your husband works outside
the home and you've been trying to do
stuff from home
yes sir okay how old are you guys 30
that sounds nice
about 36. okay all right well i knew you
was right in there somewhere based on
the mission
let's back up a second and let's look at
the whole thing
okay all right there's like four things
that jump out at me on these
conversations so far
okay
one is
you guys have to
lock arms
and write down a pledge in blood that
says i'm going to quit buying crap i
can't afford
solar panels
renovations
anything ever unless i can pay cash for
it i'm never buying it again agreed
agreed because you have impulsed
yourself into a corner
you're right
unwise purchases that put you in a
corner
right okay now that's thing one that
jumps out at me
uh i think thing two is then the two of
you are going to sit down and also start
a budget and we're going to help you i'm
going to put you into ramsey plus into
financial peace university and every
dollar if you promise me that you and
your husband will do everything i teach
you to do you can turn this around
oh absolutely i'm desperate the other
the other thing we're going to do is i'm
going to send you a copy of ken
coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose so that both of
you can begin to work on your careers
because neither one of you are
maximizing your incomes
correct you can both make more money
okay and that would help
that would that would be amazing yeah i
mean you should double your income
really in the next year yeah between you
being more effective at what you're
doing from home and between him
rethinking his whole career strategy
absolutely okay absolutely and lastly
you can have a whole lot of peace
just breathe
it in
that if none of that works
just sell the house
yes
that was what i jumped to at first yeah
and it cleared it clears everything
you're 100 debt free get you a little
rental you and your little
three-year-old
and you guys restart fresh
all your mistakes are covered by the
equities in the sale of the house you
get a fresh start i'd rather you didn't
do that
i'd rather you get your income up and
pay off 45 000 worth of debt 15 credit
card 30 solar panels and keep you paid
for cars and living on a budget you can
probably do that if you can get your
income up
i'd rather you keep the house
it's a better long-term it's a better
long-term plan
it sure is i i don't want to move i
don't want to find a new house i don't
want to put money down but you're not
you're not
you're not so far in the corner that you
can't get out
right
we can always play this card if we get
cornered
right sell the house okay that's our
last that's our last chance so what i'm
what i always do is this here's what i'm
doing with you and i do it with myself
and george we talk about this a lot in
financial coaching as well if you can
analyze your worst case scenario
and kind of emotionally swallow that and
let it get down in your stomach
and that's your worst case scenario and
and you accept it
then everything from theirs up
yeah everything's easier after that yeah
so
i know
i would cry a little but i could sell
the house and this whole thing would be
over
and so
really at that point
any other thing i try is a better plan
right right you know so okay you're okay
in other words in other words jessica
you're okay breathe you're okay
you're just behind you're in a monopoly
game and you're not winning right now
and you need to go around and pass go
and collect 200 you know
you're at baby step zero where we decide
that we're not going further into debt
we're gonna stop digging this hole
that's a big deal and then we've gotta
start baby step one and two and start
paying off the debt and you can do this
i mean this is not uh an emergency
scenario it feels like your back is
against the wall but it's just because
you can't see the forest from the trees
right now well you have absolutely no
idea where what little money is coming
in is going
you're so freaking chaotic and out of
control right now that when you sit down
and actually start doing a budget that's
also going to give you a sense of power
fabulous that sounds wonderful and so
you're it's not going to fix everything
tomorrow but you're going to go oh crap
we really can because george and i have
done enough budgets that we can look at
these numbers and go i could do that you
can do that you can do that but yours is
so frazzled and it's going off in 46 000
directions that it's hard for you to go
i mean we actually have more belief in
your situation than you do at this
moment
you sure do
turn off every screen in your house
because there's going to be another
infomercial selling you on another thing
and more solar and credit cards just
turn off the screens and get real
focused on this debt you can do this
okay so i'm going to send you i'm going
to send you the tools to do it i'm going
to send you the tools to do it kelly's
going to pick up we're going to get you
signed up for financial peace university
and ramsey plus it's going to give you
the every dollar app you get you and
your husband sit down tonight turn off
put the kid to bed turn off all the tv
sit down start working this budget
turn that car back to that friend
cut up your credit cards and start the
class and i'm also going to ship you ken
coleman's book because we're going to
start having discussions about both of
you making more money which will solve
this
but again the career has kind of been
running on
default
just whatever comes as what i do
instead of by plan and anytime you run
something by default you're running at
about 30 efficiency versus plan
execution of a detailed long-term game
plan will get you closer to 100
efficiency
and but when you just let everything
everything's just kind of been happening
to y'all and we're gonna turn this
around you're gonna start happening to
it that's right intentionality and
here's what's amazing about doing that
budget the first time you do it you want
to throw up because you realize how much
money you've wasted you went i thought
we were spending 200 on food and then
you start to do a budget get on a plan
start tracking it slim things down and
you feel that hope that's what this is
about all right so kelly paycheck to
purpose and ramsay plus we're going to
take care of you jessica you called me
back anytime
you get scared we will walk with you
through this
we know you can do this if we can
convince you to go do it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour
this is a baby steps millionaires theme
hour
if you are a millionaire we want to talk
to you and find out how you did it
[Music]
my eighth number one best-selling book
baby steps millionaires came out in
january i was not really intending to
write another book but i kept running
into people who had become millionaires
and i kept hearing all the hope stealers
out there on social media and the hope
stealers on the news pod broadcast
saying that america is dead and it's
impossible for you to build wealth out
there now and yet i was meeting people
who had done it everywhere so i knew the
hope steelers were lying
hope steelers generally are liars but we
have proven it now time and time again
it evolved into me jumping on the air
here and starting to take calls from
millionaires learning from them how they
did it
that led us into uh the largest study of
millionaires ever done in north america
airtight research that ramsay research
did it led into a chris hogan ramsey
personality at that time doing a book
called everyday millionaires that was a
best-selling book and then my follow-up
book is about the baby steps
millionaires the ones who did it made
following the baby steps like the guy we
met just a few minutes ago at one of the
breaks who said he had a net worth of
tens of millions of dollars and he'd
done it all following the baby steps and
they were out traveling america enjoying
it right now and
um
you know he was not 92 years old
he uh
was not he was not 30 but he was not 92
and he's out enjoying his money so a
millionaire george the definition of a
millionaire is an accounting function
yeah this comes down to net worth what
you own minus what you owe so if you've
got a paid for house of 500 000 and you
have 500 000 in your 401k by definition
you are a millionaire no well millions
not enough doesn't matter that's doesn't
that's not what we're discussing what
we're saying is it's not a million
dollar income the debt it's not a
million dollar income and it's not a
moral construct and it's not a
discussion of if it's enough it's a
number when you have
a one million dollar net worth or
greater you are by definition a
millionaire well i don't feel rich it's
not a feeling
it is a
math number
and that's you know but it is a
milestone that says you have established
more wealth than most people yeah
there's only america there's only about
15 million millionaires in north america
wow and so there's a whole bunch of
people that aren't in other words so it
is a legitimate that's a top 15 million
you know of the people in america in
terms of wealth building
so that's what we're discussing if you
are a millionaire we want to hear from
you we want to know how you did it
michelle is in baton rouge michelle
what's your net worth
hi dave
um i'm at about 1.5
okay cool give or take give me a little
breakdown on that by category how much
in real estate how much in retirement
plans and so forth
okay um
645
in
investment properties
100 in retirement accounts
another 350 that we're getting ready to
invest
you know like
mutual funds
um we sold some real estate so we're
getting ready to just move that into
those kind of accounts about 50 in cash
about 371
in our home so it's almost paid off
um
40 000 in cars and 16 000 in an
emergency fund good for you how old are
you
54. cool and how much of this 1.5
million dollars
net worth did you inherit
um about
38
000 when i was in college okay
so are you a millionaire because of this
inherited money
no not at all
all right and what has been the
arrangement what's been the range of
your household working income
best year and worst year since you
started
oh gosh okay um
worst year i guess about 50
and the best year about 200. cool what
do you do for a
living i'm a real estate agent and i've
had investment properties most of my
life um used to be in
home building
you got a four-year degree land
development i do
and what general studies okay
all right cool never knew what i wanted
to be there you go and your gpa when you
did that
uh three
and uh how much i mean you did real
estate so this may be a different answer
than a lot of times but how much of this
wealth do you have you think because you
used debt
to build wealth
um i mean i'm kind of an oddball because
i i was not i'm still not a saver
[Music]
i've always been
kind of an entrepreneur and
you know this was we started this in the
90s and i knew nothing about
saving or investing and everything we
did was because of debt but then i got
to a point where i couldn't handle it
anymore
and wanted to sleep at night and i i
just realized that
i just don't want to do business that
way so you built up some assets built up
some investment real estate with debt on
that real estate but then work to get
work to get it paid off so you could
sleep
yes
all right good absolutely good yeah wow
you're impressive so i want to encourage
people so far you have a general studies
degree with a 3.0 gpa
and you only inherited 38 000 and you're
have one and a half million net worth at
54 years old not even not even close to
retirement age are you still working as
a real estate agent
i am yes awesome
what advice would you give the uh what
advice would you give the 25 year old
version of you that's listening right
now
oh gosh okay
if i had had you back then i would have
done so much better
um
i tried to
instill in my kids you know they both
graduated from college debt-free so
that's amazing
to read books and learn about finance
and and you don't have to live like
all the other people that you see
driving down the road you know i'm i
just
have a lot i feel blessed and um i mean
i live in a town where there are a lot
of wealthy people and it's just you have
to kind of look past that just be
yourself and educate yourself
on finance you think it's still possible
today to start from nothing and be a
millionaire in america
i absolutely do okay cool yeah hey thank
you for the call we appreciate you
you're a hero
very very interesting wow
well the hope steelers always say well
you can't really be a millionaire you
have you know all wealth is transferred
among the wealthy families so if you
don't have a rich uncle you're boxed out
because everybody everybody knows you
inherit money is the only way you become
and yet the millionaire study and you'll
hear the calls today we take calls from
anybody if you inherited your money i'm
fine with that
but the millionaire study found that 79
of the millionaires inherited zero
another five percent only a small amount
like five thousand dollars and another
five percent
a lot of money but after they were
already millionaires
so 89 of america's millionaires did not
become
millionaires because of inherited money
including michelle
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour where we talk to
real millionaires and we find out how
they really did it not what your broke
brother-in-law's opinion is
you hear me say it all the time everyone
needs a will and it's true it's a basic
adult responsibility and there's no good
excuse to not have a will
the fastest most cost effective way to
get your will taken care of is online
but a lot of folks still ask me if a
simple online will is right for everyone
i get that do you need a trust do you
need a mirror will what about the powers
of attorney that you need to help you
answer these questions our team built a
quiz
that will help you decide on the right
option
you'll get custom results based on basic
info like you're married or single where
you live even the size of your estate
once you're done you're going to unders
understand exactly what you need it's
completely free go to
ramseysolutions.com
wills quiz
ramsey solutions dot com slash wills
quiz to check it out for yourself the
quiz takes just a few minutes and will
put you on the path to protect your
family and your wishes
ramsey solutions dot com slash wills
quiz it's a baby steps millionaires
theme hour we're talking to real
millionaires steven is in raleigh north
carolina stephen what is your net worth
well right now it's about 3.1 million
good for you give me a little breakdown
on that by category
well in
real estate it's
about 8.75
in
investments like
roth traditional iras 401ks
that type of thing it's uh
500 and
you know
76 thousand dollars i guess
and then
the biggest issue i have is cash
just in a regular savings account
drawing a whole lot of nothing 1.6
million dollars okay
all right why all the cash
well when i sold my company a couple
years ago
uh we just left it in the bank uh where
we'd been banking when i had my company
oh okay and uh
it was drawing at that point the bank
was giving us two and a quarter percent
and it looked pretty good each month and
you know the market could do whatever it
wanted and it was still there so it was
like we kind of got complacent
okay but uh since then the bank has kind
of cut the rate so i got to do something
with it gotcha okay so half of your net
worth you grew a company and sold it
asset again half of your net worth is
because you grew a company and sold it
absolutely yes okay all right how old
are you
69. what kind of company was that
it was a millwork company we assembled
uh interior and exterior door units for
the housing trade gotcha okay
and how much of your 3.1 million did you
inherit
zero zero no rich uncles okay what was
your best was your best income year and
your worst income year since you've been
working
well the worst was uh
back in 1974 was about three thousand
dollars okay uh
because i was making a buck seventy five
an hour and i thought you know that was
a road to riches back then minimum wage
uh the best was in about 2 000 it was
about 150.
okay good for you
so you systematically invested in your
401k you grew your company and you've uh
invested in real estate and you paid it
off
correct okay that's because you tell us
to pay off our house all the time so i
thought that must be the way to do it
okay it worked out for you i love you it
did you did yeah do you have a four-year
degree
uh i got a 40-year degree in working but
as far as education
i uh i had one year of college and then
i got a letter from the united states
military that said congratulations
you're now a member of the armed forces
and took me out of college and that was
the end of my college career wow thank
you for your service yes sounds like
you're welcome
sounds like uh that might have been
vietnam
uh it was during that time but uh
luckily uh each month i was told i was
going over there but i ended up down in
fort benning georgia for two years okay
all right cool so no ivy league schools
guess that's not the path
so when you hear people uh
out there say that the american dream is
dead
do you believe that uh you could still
become a millionaire if you were 20
years old right now
absolutely i've i've actually got a
five-step work plan that i preached to
my employees i managed two different
companies before i started my own and i
preached these steps to every
person that worked for me but actually i
didn't say they worked for me they
worked with me
good leader yeah well done
good for you what advice do you have to
that 20 year old what's the main thing
they need to do
well the first thing that i told all of
them
that worked with me which were usually
younger people
is to find
what you enjoy or what you have a
passion for
so it doesn't become a job because i say
a job is just overboard boredom that's
what j.o.b means just overboard them if
you have a job you don't like
it's basically boarded
and the other thing i told them to show
if you show up on time you're late
because
you need to get there a few minutes
early to kind of get your mind straight
and go
and i can't even tell you how many
employees that i had
that told me before i hired them they
said if you hire me i'll give you 110
i'm not looking for that i was looking
for somebody to give me a hundred
percent because i want anything 110
just give me 100 of your time when
you're on the job like work while you're
at work and stuff yeah
that's amazing i'd buy a book of his
one-liners they were great oh yeah you
can just fill in george when i'm gone i
like it very well done stephen good
stuff thank you sir for sharing your
numbers kathleen uh what is your net
worth in round rock texas
hi dave it's about um 2.3
cool give me a little breakdown by
category please
so we have about 1.6 million in
investments and that includes retirement
and non-retirement accounts and about
700 000 in cash and property
okay look at that all right that easy
how old are you
i am 41 and my husband is 46. okay great
and how much of this 2.3 did you inherit
zero
okay
and what was your best household year
working income and your worst
um
so our best was about 180
my income fluctuated um
taking time off and part time with young
kids um
so our best was about 180 we are
currently over the last 10 years that's
been our average um currently we're at
220 so i guess our best is now
um and lowest was
um
together so we married for seven almost
eight years and um together our lowest
was probably about um
140. okay cool what do you do for a
living
i'm a social worker what about your
husband and
my husband is a um computer science
engineer okay
so you have a you have a four-year
degree in social work or a master's
anyway what was your master's is was it
in social work
yes masters in social work okay and what
was your gpa
about 3.5 good for you okay
uh do you think this can still be done
absolutely i think more now than ever
before how did you become i mean what do
you say you when people say how you
become a millionaire by the time you're
40 actually a 2 millionaire by the time
you're 40. it's pretty impressive
you know we
i would say just invest what you can as
much as you can
when you can so we started investing
um very early and we maxed out our 401
we always paid
towards the principal on any loans so
um we we have two paid off houses we
just pay everything off early as quickly
as we as we can
and just save
we don't
my mom gave us some advice when we were
when i was young she said she always
said don't nickel and jump yourself away
i like that that's good get out of that
stay out of debt and invest there you go
that's the key it's hard it's hard it's
really hard simple but difficult yeah
well done
all right it's a baby steps millionaire
theme hour with my co-host george
campbell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you that's why you need to get in touch
with churchill mortgage to make sure you
do this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour a millionaire is someone that has a
one million dollar net worth or greater
what you own minus what you owe equals
one million dollars that makes you a
millionaire it doesn't mean you're a
better person
it doesn't mean you're smarter it means
you've got a million dollars
that's what it means
uh it doesn't mean really anything else
but it is a milestone along the way on
your wealth building journey to say
i did it if you're a baby steps
millionaire it means you did it
following the baby steps that we teach
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host we started doing this theme hour
because i got tired of hearing the lies
out there that are defeatist victim
mentality
crap by these hope stealers saying it
can't be done that everybody inherited
their wealth well we've talked to three
millionaires so far this hour none of
them are millionaires because of
inherited wealth 89 of the millionaires
in the millionaire study that we did are
not inherited uh you also hear that you
know the only way you get rich is you
rip people off you're a crook
you heard that one george yeah yeah
you've gotta you gotta hurt someone to
get on top there that's just not how it
works
you got to rip someone off scam them
into the money
you know that's just so
illogical it's dumb
you know it's just dumb okay let's just
think about this for a second all right
so you're running a business
i don't know let's make it up uh you're
a car repair guy
okay
and uh you're a crook because that's how
you get rich you being a crook right
so when i go in and get my car fixed you
rip me off
so what am i gonna do
tell everybody i know don't go to that
guy he's a crook and you go out of
business eventually how does he get rich
doing that he goes out of business he
doesn't get rich
or
i go in there and he fixes the car
in five minutes
and comes out and says um i say how much
is it he goes you know the part was was
a quarter and it took me five minutes
i'm gonna charge you anything
but just any time you need you know
anytime you need car work come on over
and you know we'll get we'll do your car
repair
not only am i coming back
don't tell everybody i know
so how do crooks prosper again
that's the most moronic thing i've ever
heard
that you get rich by screwing people
well and it's quite the opposite if you
have a lot of money it means you must
lack integrity the free market economy
will take care of your butt
if you have a lack of integrity if
you're making money by screwing people
word will get out hello
you know
that's just dumb
it's just so victim
childish
left-wing nut job thinking socialist
thinking that it just blows my mind
that's just cray-cray man doesn't make
any sense or if you want to be a
millionaire you have to be a famous
entertainer
or a sports
person you're playing the nba and then
fl
the nhl whatever because they get 25
million dollar contracts yeah well
you'll get to be a mainer if you do that
by the way or you should be but you may
not pay outspend a lot of them don't
keep it but um
you know but but here's the thing less
than one percent of millionaires
are
athletes or entertainers
so it's you have a 99
greater probability to become a
millionaire doing something else
and our top five list doesn't include
any of those our top 10 list doesn't our
top 20 list doesn't shocking in the
research but now we
truthfully we did not set out to
interview the rich and famous
the famous rich we wanted to find people
that look like you
and just everyone the other one you know
all these things are trying to say you
can't do it that's why i call them help
stealers
you know the other one is you have to be
brilliant
i mean you have to have like a 4.2 gpa
and occasionally i talk to a millionaire
that's got a 4.2 but almost all of them
have a round of three
uh i famously have a 2.97 and i'm still
pissed about the three one hundredths of
a minute they couldn't just bump you one
too many beer pong games i'm just saying
but yeah there you go so but the uh uh
yeah you know but it's not an iq so you
can but you don't have that i don't find
them to have a 1.5 gpa i mean you do
have to have some great can be dumber
than a rock you can't be dumber than a
rock but you don't have to be like a
rocket scientist or a rocket surgeon so
somewhere between a dumb rock and a
rocket scientist there you go all right
so you know you got to be bright but
yeah you know smart enough to be able to
do the sixth grade math to get there but
it's more about behavior than it is in
iq exactly
brian is in austin texas brian what's
your net worth
hi david um george appreciate you taking
my call our net worth is 1.8 million
good for you give me a little break down
by category boss
sure it's 1.1 million of investments uh
so 550 of that is in tax deferred
accounts 300 000 in roth accounts and we
have 250 000 in index funds and a
taxable account good for you okay
yeah and then we have uh 550 000 of home
equity and vehicles 100 000 and 529 for
our two kids and 50 000 in cash which is
our emergency fund cool how old are you
38. good for you young millionaire way
to go man
how much of this 1.8 did you inherit
so none we were blessed to be able to
build our home um on a small plot of
family-owned land but we actually don't
include that land in our net worth so
it's not in any of the numbers
why is it not yours
uh so i don't feel i i'm allowed to sell
it so it's my
it's my privilege to work on it and
responsibility and it's my job to pass
it down so it's not
so i don't consider it marketable okay
so if you can't sell you can't count on
your net worth i got that okay so what's
been your best year working income and
worst year working income since you guys
started
sure so our
first year was our worst year we made
about forty six thousand dollars back
when we just graduated from college
um and then last year we made 170 000.
good for you what do you do for a living
so i'm a cpa serving as a corporate
controller for a non-profit in austin
and then my wife has had the much more
challenging job the stay-at-home mom and
she now homeschools our two kids okay
cool so you've obviously got a degree in
accounting
yes and your gpa
uh undergrad was 3.9 okay all right
you're the smartest we've found a smart
one found the smart one today good for
you
good very good good job okay so you're
you did this at 38 years old
um and by the way accountant is the
number two most likely
uh career of someone becoming a
millionaire number one is engineer
number three is teacher
uh so you're right in the category there
you're 38 if you're looking back 20
years and talking to an 18 year old what
would you tell them can they still do
this and what should they do
so they they can absolutely still do it
it's definitely still possible um it's
in my opinion it's certainly not easy
but it's really simple you marry well
you make goals
make a budget and spend less than you
make and automate saving the difference
and if you do that consistently
over time you will certainly become
financially free
okay let me go back because some people
when you said mary well heard that you
married into money
no i used to have i used to have a guy
running around with college that was his
plan to get rich he was going to marry a
debutant right that it sounds like the
dream right it's a legal way to do it
mary well as in mary a partner who is
with you through thick and thin that you
can trust and rely on yeah try to avoid
um
marrying somebody who's irresponsible
yeah good throw off your plan yeah
that's good man that's great very cool
38 years old that's very impressive yeah
that's a young millionaire well done sir
well done we're proud of you thanks for
calling in and sharing that that's good
stuff
so um
you know interesting that none of us go
do something
unless we believe
that it's gonna work
okay you don't put gas in your car
unless you believe that it's gonna cause
your car to run
you don't save money into an account
unless you believe it's gonna be there
so our belief proceeds our actual action
when we surveyed millionaires and asked
if they believed
that you could be a millionaire today
and if they believed it when they were
in the process of becoming a millionaire
98
said yes
your belief
supersedes pre-disposes your actions
when we surveyed the general public
ask the same question
69
percent said they believed it could
still be done the hope steelers brought
this the data down the hope steelers
look at that they're out there they're
hope vampires they're sucking the blood
out of your hole
man it can be done and it's amazing if
you just believe it and you follow it
with behavior well you're not going to
do it if you don't think you can oh
henry ford quote if you think you can or
you think you can't you're right
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalms 18
it is god who arms me with strength and
keeps my way
secure
henry ford said if everyone is moving
forward together
then success
takes care of itself
then success
takes care
of itself
pretty important stuff right there this
is a millionaire theme hour deuteronomy
8 18 says and you shall remember the
lord your god
for it is he
who gives you
power
to get
wealth
it's in the bible wow who knew who knew
in deuteronomy nonetheless yeah
yeah i expect that from proverbs but
deuteronomy is a surprise digging around
down there in the legalists yeah i love
it it's fun
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're talking to real
millionaires not broke people with an
opinion
we want to know what it really feels
like looks like to get to be a
millionaire and how did you get there
and what do you do so that we can give
you the opportunity to do just that
melinda is in houston texas melinda
what's your net worth
um 1.7 good for you and give me a little
break down on that by category please
okay
if it sounds like i'm making any of this
up i'm really nervous but i grabbed a
brown paper bag that's okay
um okay
real estate
uh we actually just paid cash for our
first time ever paying for a house good
for you and
that was 440.
and then we have
cash iras vehicles we had just sold our
business and we're trying to find
something else to invest in
so that's kind of the breakdown there's
not exact but
we just moved so my net worth that she
is in a box somewhere
no troubles no troubles how old are you
uh 62. good for you okay cool how much
of your 1.7 in net worth did you inherit
oh we we didn't inherit any of it okay
and what's been your best year of
working income and your worst year
working income for your whole household
since you guys started working
um it goes from zero to
about 130 000. cool what do y'all do for
a living
well we sold our business so we haven't
done anything since august got it what
was the business
uh
grinding tree stumps
okay all right
cool uh any of you got a four-year
degree
no
okay
high school right okay good for you
remember what your gpa was back in high
i school know okay it's all right no
problem no problem that's fun good for
you what do you tell people can they
still do it
um we didn't start until 15 years ago so
we were 47
and
i would tell people what we realized
pretty quickly was that when you
want to be successful you spend money
based on what you have saved for and not
the balance in the checking account
and i don't know how many people i've
met that
spend based on what is in the account
and they constantly check it
and you have to stop doing that because
we were doing it so i recognize i know
you know what they're doing
you have to save
money in categories envelopes in a
budget on a spreadsheet whatever you
have to do and then when you go to the
grocery store you actually go by that
amount and not the amount that you have
in the checking account well that's
that's that is that's everything stick
to a plan
well done well done hey thanks for
sharing with us mark is with us in
dayton ohio mark how much your net worth
my net worth is 1.3 million good for you
okay give me a little breakdown by
category
so with zero debt no mortgage we have
700 000 in retirement investments 500 in
traditional 200 and roth
we own a 400 000 home and we have 200
dollars in cash
good for you how old are you
i am 50 years old good for you cool and
how much of this 1.3 did you inherit
uh we
initially got five thousand dollars from
the passing of my mother and we
unintentionally we invested in universal
life but got smarter as we figured that
that part out
okay so you're not a millionaire because
of inheritance
no not at all not close even yeah okay
so what was your best year of income and
your worst year of income since you guys
have been working household income
i started out with 20 000 when i
enlisted in the air force when i was
graduating high school okay and your
best year my best my best year is 138
000 as a civil service uh government
worker for a combined total of 200 000 a
year gotcha okay
all right good and um well thank you for
your service so what was your main
career in service or civil service
it was service uh i did 22 years and
then i retired after i was commissioned
i got and then i retired and then i went
back in civil service and i worked for
the u.s space force as their technical
director cool did you go get a four-year
degree
i did and the military helped obtain
that goal
and yeah what was your degree in
the computer science and information my
master's was in information systems
management a master's good for you okay
and what was your gpa
3.8 for the bachelor's and a 3.9 for my
master's gotcha okay sharp guy yeah mark
how much of it was in uh cryptocurrency
zero wow okay i just wanted to check
they're out there apparently people are
getting rich off this
yeah i have a wonderful wife that has a
moderate risk level and that's
definitely not one she's interested in i
i can suspect yeah all right cool
so what would you tell the younger
version of you 20 years old 25 years old
listening right now
a quarter of a century back there can
they still do it and if so what should
they do
yes and i'll tell you i'm going through
that now i have three young daughters
both two of them that are 24 to 21 and
one that's in college both all three
debt free
and i'm going through that now i sit
there and tell them you know
systematically investments we started
with the ben and arthur kind of study
that showed all those investments
and said it's your job to make sure that
you not necessarily worry about wealth
but look for generational peace
[Music]
that's good i like that a lot
well done sir thank you for sharing your
story we appreciate it very good stuff
this gives me hope dave well yeah i mean
you look down to it okay we got a 1.5 a
3.1 2.3 1.8 million 1.7 million
so a three down to 1.3 is the range
million uh net worth today
um
precisely zero and of them are there
because of inherited money um we got one
hot two high school graduates
um and then a three a three point five
three point nine three point eight gpa
so we don't have any uh geniuses but we
don't have any dummies
uh here they're all they're all getting
it done right and uh real estate uh two
of them owned companies a cpa a social
worker
and a military guy um
the two uh entrepreneurs that sold their
companies one of them was tree stumps
and one of them did uh molding and doors
and millwork
and uh sound like working people to me
yeah that's amazing and the range of
ages too is cool 38 up to 16. no rocket
surgeons in here no not a one not an
athlete not an entertainer what this
tells me is it's more about behavior and
consistency than it is about luck and
those people out there who are
millionaires they don't deserve it the
way they got there was not ethically
right and no one should be millionaires
evil rich people that's what the hope
steelers all say those people didn't
sound evil to me they sounded like
people that go to the grocery store next
to me i didn't hear a single crook
not that we could tell well that's true
that's right they may have been they may
have been if they're
a good crook then we wouldn't know right
oh man what a bunch of
crap that some of you believe
and some of you say out there and you
need to stop it
we have a picture in our minds of what
billionaires look like and we have to
reset that everything a high quality
moral person of character
has the highest probability to succeed
in the united states of america today
now we have data to prove that
that virtue matters and a bunch of you
are running around with hate
and nastiness on your breath
and your breath stinks
we're just saying you should stop it
take a breath minute guys it's called
the baby steps
there we go
thanks george good show
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's
[Music]
debt ramseysolutions.com screen
[Music]
you